don't like when people attempt but that
was almost so good would you just give
him a card what the [__] is happening
I own a recruitment Agency for it
professionals
[Applause]
that I am at you I thought you came here
because you were a fan you're just out
here it's because you're out here
soliciting ain't that crazy your company
was like we need you to go to a career
fair and you're like I am I got you I
don't worry Friday 7 30. that is
actually planning ahead that's not
racism that's stereotyping correctly you
were right if you were wrong it would
have been [__] up but literally within
arms reached there's six [__]
potential candidates right here
you're gonna get a whole ass bonus off
of my show I'm not gonna see a dollar
off of this when you need your house
worked on you come to like a Gabrielle
Iglesias show or what do you do
I need to remodel the kitchen what is
Fluffy in town